tras años de vaivenes aparece que el
acuerdo comercial entre el mercosur y la
Unión Europea está un poco más cerca
fueron necesarios 20 años de
negociaciones para que en 2019
finalmente se llegará a un acuerdo entre
los dos bloques este incluía diálogo
político temas económicos y comerciales
y cooperación no obstante nunca se
aplicó y está pendiente de ratificación
el motivo los temores de países miembros
de la Unión Europea como Francia a que
la exportación de carne Sudamericana
afecte a sus ganaderos entre otros
entonces Que ha cambiado ahora respecto
al acuerdo comercial tras la victoria
del progresista Luis Ignacio Lula da
Silva en Brasil a finales de 2022 una de
las primeras visitas fue la dolab a
Shoes canciller de Alemania y otros
mandatarios europeos un claro signo de
las intenciones de Lula quien remarcó
que quería que no solo Brasil sino
Sudamérica entera tuviera más peso en la
Esfera internacional por otra parte este
posible acuerdo también conviene a la
Unión Europea en un momento en el que
China y Rusia están forjando alianzas
geopolíticas desde el organismo aseguran
que la relación entre la Unión Europea y
América Latina es un imperativo
estratégico sin embargo ambas partes
tienen exigencias mientras la Unión
Europea pide garantías a para no
importar productos que fomenten la
deforestación o la crisis climática
mercosur quiere restringir el acceso de
empresas internacionales a las
licitaciones a públicas no obstante
ambas potencias han prometido avances al
respecto